ton nom bat frédéric dard dit san
antonio s'est pas de blague c'est sûr
mais pas qui est le dix ans antonio
figure sur mes papiers parce que je
recevais tellement de courrier à ce nom
là quand j'allais à la poste pour les
recommandés on voulait pas me donner
envie d'aimer qui s antonio et
l'administration a bien voulu mais je
peux te faire voir
date de naissance c'est indispensable où
je parlerai qu'en présence de mon avocat
je crois que je faisais avant de devenir
chauffeur m 72 toi ça c'est variable
en ce moment je suis à la hausse bon tu
me pendant les 86 kg mais je te promets
qu'aux vacances je serai à 81 euros
principales maladies non c'est parce que
tu crois nos principales maladies que
j'ai eu écho que je te calcule au raf
maladies chroniques
oui comme la phobie du conte quoi je
crois que c'est une maladie tu as fait
ton test pour le sida non je le fais pas
parce que j'attends la bonne surprise
tu devrais te pardonner odile oms pif un
peu fort mais tu sais de ce que ça
représente significatif à bien gens
quand une dame qui est si je vois son
regard porté sur mon nez je sais qu il
j'espère beaucoup ses ventes et dont il
te reste d'origine et combien tout il
manque une que j'ai paumé ce pour mieux
il ya quinze jours ça tu avais des
cheveux il était gras ou sec
je sais pas en tout cas il était
prédisposé à [ __ ] le camp
les yeux bleus il me semble que ça soit
non je les pense à l'eau de javel tous
les matins la miotte presbytes astigmate
presbytes ça j'ai des copains qui ils
sont mais pas moi tu connais la longueur
de temps sexe enfin je voudrais pas de
faire de confidences ici parce qu'après
ailleurs un attroupement
nous avons les folies mais je dois faire
un aveu il ya longtemps je n'ai pas
mesuré j'aurais peut-être une déception
depuis
signe particulier oui j'ai le bras
gauche et ce qui a été donné naissance
au vieux combien tu prends de suite par
semaine à sa suite plus par semaine
avant ça c'était par jour à mes débuts
c'était par jour alors c'était deux par
jour quand j'étais journaliste à lyon tu
vois et puis je suis devenu raisonnable
ça s'est limité à deux par semaine c'est
maintenant je crois que ça doit être de
parents tabac chiche cocaïne morphine
non je vais te dire moi j'aime pas me
déformer la vie au point que l'été je
mets pas de lunettes de soleil parce que
je trouve que c'est deschamps
stupéfiants tu vois que ça te dit que
l'or l'existence moi j'aime voir les
choses et les gens tels qu'ils sont
fréquence hebdomadaire des rapports
sexuels
je pense
enfin plusieurs fois tu a recours à la
vente arif et non non ça alors c'était
dans les débuts mais c'était pas par
avarice 1 parce que je suis le conteur
de talent mais je suis pas je trouve une
espèce de tristesse puis quand tu penses
que tout le monde est disponible
rude coup pour payer tu as eu des
expériences homosexuelles
non bien sûr non enfin si tu veux j'ai
comme j'avais il ya 12 13 ans j'ai
touché la queue d'un pote et qui m'ont a
fait autant en fait ça n'a pas dégénéré
quoi qu'à d'autres perversion sexuelle
en jeu mais je mersey et d'autres
perversion je crois que ma plus grande
perversion c'est d'écrire parce que
j'écris sans arrêt sans arrêt sans la
région de soul d'écriture ma bruti
d'écriture j'ai besoin car je sais que
j'ai fini d'écrire je sors en mouvement
quelques fois je vais prendre une douche
je suis gros geek je suis à montceau
d'écriture alors je crois que ça
équivaut presque à une perversion du
cloud est sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou